this is a production of Cornell
University
my name is Jacob Johnston I'm with the
project yard map at the Cornell Lab of
Ornithology a citizen science program
aimed at creating habitat in your yard
yard maps essentially allows scientists
to better understand how landscape use
and gardening choices affected birds and
wildlife populations in a residential or
urban settings now most of us have yards
that were at one time a wild space
before it was a yard before it was a
city before was a neighborhood before
was anything and so we're sort of
getting back into this culture we're
looking at ways that we can share the
space with ecological term ecological
sort of concepts and techniques using
ecology it in the way that it was has
been proceeding through you know
centuries of time in order to coexist
basically there's been a new
understanding of sharing spaces and a
new concern for their you know a greater
concern for the environment over time
and so you know the yard map seeks to
you know help I guess use that concern a
little bit but also nurture it and and
help people to make better decisions
based on education and that's one thing
that citizen science is really all about
is using the public to not only teach
them more about what they're doing and
what they're interested in but also to
provide better data back for us so that
we can create better best use practices
best practices and things like that to
send back out to those citizen sciences
and to the community so in a sharing
ecologically sharing this space you
would have room for you you you would
have your yard you would have you know
vegetable garden or something like that
and you have some wild areas and some
cones some structure and some some
native lands around it to you like
forest edges so a lot of us are our
backyard conservationists these days
it's you know nature is becoming a very
big part of the environmentalism is
becoming a very big part of our culture
and society and we know that there's a
lot of people out there that are
enthusiastic about it that they want to
participate in protecting and protecting
nature and conserving while birds wild
flowers trees and now there's this great
big push for pollinators like bees and
butterflies and hummingbirds so how do
we engage the backyard conservationists
how do we get people to put forth the
effort and collaborate and work together
and join knowledge and essentially be a
more refined and robust tool well that's
what that's what the cone a lab of
ornithology excels at and what we do
here is a focus collective attempt
collective talents to you know to solve
problems
that people in urban and residential
areas maybe maybe noticing we have lots
of programs at the Cornell Lab of
Ornithology that monitored different
types of environments different types of
habitats and different types of
activities that birds and other of
course another wildlife engage in and
the more citizen scientists we have out
there telling us what you know is going
on in the backyards and the
neighborhoods and things like that of
places then the more we can understand
how those animals are using it what they
need and what is not working and what is
working at the lab we revolve around
bird conservation currently there's over
350,000 people engaged in bird
conservation activities those are
citizen scientists mostly so why birds
why are we interested in birds what is
it special about birds that has such a
draw and has such an engagement with the
public and they're very charismatic your
indicators of environmental health their
migration patterns and distributions and
tell us a lot about the environments
that they use the habitats there that
they utilize and where they where they
can and can't go basically they tell us
that the population densities and their
abundance and diversity can tell us a
lot about the environmental health as
well they occur in all different types
of habitats this is a greater prairie
chicken that occurs in a very small
year-round range and from about Kansas I
think up through North Dakota just in a
small band there then you've got the
arctic tern who has a 24,000 25,000 mile
migration range from pole to pole it
takes an entire year so this bird here
is you know circum global whereas the
other one if it's a very small niche
habitat that's pretty pretty specific to
what it needs the arctic tern as well on
the coasts and in the polls where it has
where it breeds and over winters
you know requires a certain type of
habitat but also all the spaces in
between every connecting point that it
lands and stops on its year-round
migration needs to be some sort of
habitat and some sort of space for it so
we use the birds because they encompass
the entire globe and they encompass
almost every aspect of our lives they
have really unique inning
amazing behaviors this killdeer is known
for its impressive display of being
broken or wounded when you approached
its nest it builds a nest here in the
gravel you might even be able to find a
nest if you look closely in the gravel
but it's very camouflaged and when a
predator or a threat approaches the nest
they sort of limp away with a broken
wing they bend their wing funny so it
looks broken so these intricate and
unique habits the birds have you know
interest people they really grab
people's attention you become these
charismatic fauna that gained support
from the public
they can be anything from meat to
majestic like this red tail hawk here
it's found across the country
and they're very integrated into our
into our lives into our urban and rural
landscapes we share the whole we share
our world with them whether we know it
or not if you can see the snowy owl in
this picture there it is which is a you
know not all that you see very often but
they do incorporate themselves into our
landscape and so what we want to know is
how can we best coexist with them
because you know they incorporate
they're going to live there they're
going to be around how many they are and
how healthy they are is sort of up to us
now that we understand what their needs
are so birding is a very very popular
recreational pastime 85 million
Americans across the country participate
yearly nine hundred million dollars are
invested annually in bird watching and
birding and support like this one of our
biggest programs at the lab of
ornithology here in citizen science is
the e bird program we also have the
project feeder watch with head which has
17,000 users that participate in a
four-month eater watch study through the
winter in the early spring where they
watch they put out bird feeders and
without different types of feed and
different types of feed food for the
birds and that then they collect the
data they count the birds and they
report that data through online tools
nest watch crew 32 percent in 2013 and
it's on track now to break the 20,000
nest record I'm sorry to break a record
of 20,000 nests protected so they're
there they're really getting big and
popular and this is a program that you
can participate in where you locate
nests you actually have to take a
training course and learn how to be a
part of this citizen science project so
that you don't infringe on the safety or
the health of these birds while they're
nesting and so a lot of people really
appreciate that and learn a lot of
appreciation and respect and have a lot
of gained admiration through projects
like this another one that
really popular is Cubs celebrate urban
birds this one boasts over 250,000
members from 23,000 urban areas they
mentor disadvantaged kids and they even
have a program where they teach birding
by ear to blind youths so we have all
these programs and they're all online
and they have some of the Cornell Lab of
Ornithology has some of the best tools
for engaging citizen scientists
but there's one
that's missing something that's a little
more personal a little more closer to
all of us
and that's our yard now why would we
want to focus on yards what exactly is
about is it with yards that drew our
attention it made us want to reach out
to people
well if we take a look at the average
American yard we see that it's not
really bird friendly in fact it's not
really environmentally friendly so the
average American lon is about sixty
percent of the sixty percent grass and
it contains a lot of impervious areas
like the grass like the driveway here
and the rooftops there's usually a small
area for maybe a flower or vegetable
garden but most of our are your heart
most of our property our American yard
is lon and that lawn is not a very good
habitat so we try to encourage a
reduction in lon it's actually one of
our nation's biggest crop and it's not
very good habitat so with this
increasing growth of urban and
residential areas across the country
every day or every year I'm sorry about
the size of West Virginia becomes
settled urbanized for somehow turned in
from wild habitat into human habitat so
the growth is is growing at a rate that
is hard to keep up with and so what we
want to do is instead of changing that
habitat into something else we want to
work with that habitat with yard man
which I encourage people to think small
with their lawns be environmentally
friendly use other type of landscaping
in your yard
besides a lawn that is more effective
and more efficient in providing habitat
for birds and wildlife something like
this there's a be there there's a
collection of wildflowers this is
obviously much more bountiful and
plentiful and environmentally friendly
for any sort of creatures that may be
wandering through your yard or flying
overhead so how do we create habitat for
birds and wildlife in our yard what are
the main ingredients what is it that we
need to focus on well the main
ingredients is our food water and
shelter just like anything
and freedom from danger which is
something that isn't always at the top
of the list or the front of our thoughts
when we're creating habitat in our yards
food water shelter and freedom from
danger creates the habitat but what do
we mean when we talk about food
bird feeder with seed is good
food for birds in that sense most people
don't realize though or maybe they don't
realize that birds eat more than seed
they eat bugs most birds eat mostly bugs
here's a stern blue bird doing the
caterpillar thwomp I think they call it
are they it's a high for smash on to
something that breaks the skin apart it
makes it easier to digest and what are
the e caterpillar is a single pair of
breeding chickadees need 75,000
caterpillars per season to raise 325
nestlings
so how do we get these caterpillars how
do we bring in the bugs to feed the
birds well if we look at some data that
was produced shortly ago we really see
that caterpillar richness the diversity
of caterpillars the number of
caterpillars and the number of species
are greatly outnumber the number of
caterpillars in the number of species on
non native or introduced invasive plants
as compared to native plants if you look
and then woody plants are even much
greater attracted to butterflies and
anything else that lays eggs and
produces caterpillars or larvae
you
so to provide food we need to provide
plans that provide bugs that provide the
food
we also need to provide water for birds
they get water out of the food they eat
and they get water flying around of you
know over lakes and ponds and things
they're there they move around a lot but
they don't always
they don't move a lot every day or
see I'm sorry mixed up here
you
so providing water in strategic places
across the landscape such as yards
really makes this connectivity across
the landscape and increases their
chances of finding habitats
so when we when we talk about water so
it could be anything if you don't have a
pond or a creek running through your
yard if you do then you're providing
water if you don't save here in a
suburban area or a dense urban area then
there's a lot of other ways you can
provide water for birds like bird baths
and here are some tips that we provide
on yard map for the you know for ideal
birdbath
because we want them to be safe we want
them to be clean and we don't want them
to be traps if you have too deep of a
bird bath or if it's not clean on a
regular basis or if it's shrouded by
shrubs or trees then it can be preyed on
by cats things like that so we one of
the great things about citizen science
is this back and forth this call and
response is you know put water in your
yard well then we get this you know
response back well you know I put water
in my yard but you know these birds
drowned in it well why did they drown in
it so we understand you know what better
and more effective and efficient types
of water can provide for birds you know
and it goes back and forth
sure is another thing was very important
to provide a new yard for birds in
structure to perch on to display from
from mating to call from they need
structure to build nests in and
structure can be any number of things
structure means anything from vertical
height to horizontal width to texture
here's a little
advertisers that we put out through yard
map that talks about the diversity of
structure in your yard birds aren't
taxon unless they don't necessarily know
the species of the plants in your yard
but they do know the texture of the
needles or the leaves they do know the
density of the branches that you know
the height of the tree or the quality of
the wood that is being built they know
that they're building their nests out of
or something like that and so having a
diversity their items sorry they're
actually experts at what they need we're
and we are the ones that are capable of
providing it or not taking it away say
if we're building a new home somewhere
and instead of clearing all the trees
from an area you could leave them adjust
and even this is another thing that we
promote here is dead trees sometimes
dead trees are more productive and more
provide more to have more species using
them then a live tree does these uh
these are called snags and they're
rotting wood and they provide homes for
all kinds of bugs which provides foods
for the birds they also provide holes
like cavities for nesting birds I mean
the other thing that we need besides
food water and shelter is freedom from
danger and this could be a number of
things freedom from danger is uh refers
to anything that may draw your your drug
or attract birds or wildlife your yard
but then hides or disguises some danger
there that you may not know of yourself
well we hear a lot about cats and oh my
cat would never you know never heard a
bird or maybe only get one or two here
and there something like that but the
reality is birds killed billions of
birds every year because there are
millions of cats maybe killing several a
year so it may not seem like much but in
the end it is a very powerful force
against bird populations like this is a
graphic that shows freedom from danger
from windows some new recent studies
have come out through
Peter watch would that show that feeders
that have are placed in the wrong space
or close too close to I'm sorry too
close to a house but not close enough
create a deadly collision zone where
Birds frightened from a feeder or
startled from a feeder will gain enough
speed but not have enough i guess
agility to to clear the house or clear a
window if they're closer to the house
their speed is not that great if they're
farther from the house and they have the
the distance to make the adjustments but
there is a zone that we found through
citizen science that you know is is more
deadly for placing feeders also when to
mow sometimes if you have large yards
mowing can endanger fledglings or
nestlings that haven't pledged yet so
all these things work together and they
all need to work together with us as we
all are integrated in this coexistence
that we're discovering more and more
about over time in terms of coexistence
were realizing also that a greater
diversity of birds and greater diversity
of plants and wildlife around a
neighborhood or around a group of people
improves their well-being this is true
in almost any demographic in almost any
society and so what yard map seeks to do
is collaborate with groups of people to
join people together and to create a
community of yard mappers a community of
people making connections or connecting
points connectivity is a very big
concept in ecology that connects large
expanses of wild areas through small
expenses of while there is like yards
you
one yard that's yard mapped and is being
managed for wildlife is great two yards
is even better because that provides
stepping stones from say a National
Forest to you know like Saranac or
something then you have you have these
stepping stones of habitat and when you
have stepping stones connected you have
corridors so you have corridors and
stepping stones and all of this you know
when a community works together to
provide all the necessity necessary or
essential parts of a habitat across the
landscape that's when we can all make a
really big difference this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu